I am a trial survivor from Poland Poland
was home to the largest Jewish
population in Europe by inviting a
Holocaust survivor you remember the
murdered Jews of Europe you keep the
memory alive
Miriam's story to me is very touching
you know being Jewish I have family who
were lost in the Holocaust and we have
no records whatsoever in many cases not
even the name and it's very touching to
see
Miriam's story and how she brought her
memories together it's inspiring it's
heartwarming it's moving I think it's
brilliant that she was able to write
this story out and go through all of
that again relive it
so Miriam in your book is all about you
know rediscovering your memory and then
sharing those memories in your story and
I was wondering what specifically
motivated you to rediscover your Jewish
heritage I don't even think that we can
speak about rediscovery because I was 8
over 8 I was born June 2nd I left home
in 41 in November so it's 8 and 3 months
I know who I was I was hiding actively
hiding so when when I returned to who I
was it was a very slow fearful process I
was really afraid so entrace
he wrote a lot about the nature of
perspective and how you remember
differently now the order as you were
writing trains how did your perspective
on your story change the story is the
same but I allowed myself as I went
along with the book I allowed myself to
admit to feelings to admit to hurt I I
think it helped me become a truer person
when I decided to tell my story and that
was after they gathered the first
gathering of trial subtitles and I stood
that way without waiting for my turn
trust ran to the middle of the room and
started talking to us words poured out
of me and
I think some recollection of things that
were there but I did not they call them
really did not handle it them like my
grandfather praying he was a Hasidic
drew and I was speaking about that and
when I sat down also by the reaction of
people that the survivors it was a
gathering of the survivors I realized
that I need to write so when I started
writing I looked at the photograph of
Miriam winter at her first communion
that's the only thing I had any nothing
physical except for that photograph and
it really went like a spiral deeper and
deeper when I allowed myself to not rush
but also to stop in the middle of the
sentence or pick up from nowhere and
just start right well there's a part of
your book where you say I am their
witness and the theme of witnessing
comes up a lot in your book what is your
goal as a witness to tell what I know
what happened my field is theater but my
hobby through my life was history and I
do know history but I do not when I
speak about the Holocaust I speak only
about the things that I know and that's
that's important for me because I'm I
want to
tell what had happened from that
perspective from what as a child during
the Holocaust in Poland what I witnessed
not what I heard
what I witnessed or what had happened so
what do you hope that students
especially will learn as they read your
story the story must be told and the
memory of what happened must be kept
alive that was that is now a very strong
motivation for many other Jewish child
survivors not only for me it definitely
is for me and I think it was so from the
very beginning to tell what happened